[Music]
huh look at this
look at this cute little meme i bet he
was thinking what
i'm still alive why has he not reviewed
me yet
maybe i get to live it's a miracle
no that's enough i don't know
it's a cute little meme everybody god
creates humans
humans create other religions god
excuse me what the er germany all right
the war is going great
don't quote me on that now we all have
now we only have to worry about russia
and great brit japan farms pearl harbor
vtf and
look at the solar system every single
other planet has been proven round
so what cluster of event led to the
earth being flat
riddle me that the earth is not a planet
excuse me
when someone uses the wrong mean
template
i don't think so use the right one
meme correction when someone tries to
take your hand
me hat alright this meme definitely
deserves to die congratulations
when you are in a crowded area and you
need to get somewhere
excuse me when the lego set says 8
to 12 years but you ate it in 30 minutes
excuse me why did i come back for this
i should have just stayed in there when
you walk into the there
are expected to be crowded king but
instead 40 centers with
with daggers jump you excuse me
excuse me what the duck i like that one
i like that one because he didn't swear
gonna give this meme a schmeckle
just like in rick and morty
or schmeckle meme update
that's right a new segment everybody
this lady
she said i'm ready to become a meme oh
no no
oh no no careful what you wish for i've
been away a couple days
it's been a wonderful time but i know
what everyone has wanted me to answer
while i was gone
what if what if all right listen
level with me here okay what if
ben shapiro was fortnite
ben where are we at fortnight
[Music]
every single day i watch this video feel
free to bookmark this video so you can
come back to this segment
as well i've got an important
announcement to make
meme announcement all right listen up
kids
this is very very important are you
writing this down
all right let's do this on august 6.
let's all go to mcdonald's and ask for
the fortnite burger
the the look on the workers face will be
awesome
are you with me okay all right how about
this on august 8th
let's all go to taco bell the look on
the workers face
will be awesome all right
okay all right okay all right okay how
about this
on august 6 let's all go to mcdonald's
and ask for all the money and the cash
register
the look on the workers face will be
awesome
on okay all right okay okay what about
this all right on august
31st we all will visit a nightclub
and ask to be let in we will pay
in v bucks i got so much v-bucks
i'll be the king of the dance floor okay
all right how about this all right
listen up
all right you're you're tough guy to
convince i get it okay all right
all right if we all work together it
will work on june 4th
1989. let's all go to the tainan men
square
and question the legitimacy of the
chinese government
the look on the communist party face
will be awesome
come on guys it'll be epic come on guys
okay all right okay all right fine what
about this on september 11
2000 no no we're not doing that we're
gonna do mcdonald's how can i help you
fortnite burger what
the look on your face is awesome
it's awesome it's awesome everything is
awesome
fortnite burger hey fortnite burger
fortnite burger fortnite
fortnite burger everybody let's all work
together
and we can make the face on people
awesome
make the world a nicer place it's nice
to finally have a meme
that just cares about positivity this
meme gets a five
extra plus for positivity and a positive
movement
i love positivity it just makes me so
positive dad
there's a monster under my bed yeah well
yes technically there is a monster under
your bed but there's no reason to be
afraid of it
have you read the ingredients what nani
nanideska nani the f what is this
this is not epic dead there's a loser
under my bed
okay this is epic okay this is epic
style what do you see under my bed bro
nothing bro that's my world without you
bro
bro all right
okay all right
[Music]
meme review what happened
am i even reviewing memes anymore i
guess i don't
bro yes bro close your eyes bro
okay bro you're a good boy bro
i know bro goodbye bro
this is so sad alexa can you play
pewdiepie playing despacito
i can't your video got copiers right
that's right everybody
apparently my cover was so good that it
got claimed by 21 parties
i guess it was just too close to the
original
thank you really appreciate that
i'll fight this and i'll fight it i'll
take it to court god damn it
close your eyes bro okay bro what you
see bro
nothing bro that's my world without you
bro
bro this is so sad
alexa can we cast obsidian
while playing despacito not the regular
one
the pewdiepie one without the copy
strike edition
thank you thank you
you don't look so good bro i'm fine bro
okay let's go tell the world we're free
bro we're free bro
why did you just whisper that to me bro
because you are
my world bro bro
[Music]
all right all memes aside well maybe not
and you guys probably heard stefan carl
stephenson uh passed away
after a two-year-long battle with cancer
normally
when someone passed away it's frowned
upon to make jokes about it
all right you can't just can't do it but
with stefan
being so active on reddit and involved
in the meme community and really
embracing with open arms the how popular
that we are number one meme became on
youtube
it was such a wonderful thing to see and
all the positivity that he spread around
it i thought it was a very nice thing to
see how many people memed
stefan in such a positive way after he's
passing away as well
so i thought it would make sense to
bring up on meme review
it's time to go was i a good mane
no i'm told you were the base lodge
sucks did an
art piece for him you either die a
villain or you live long enough to see
yourself become the hero
this is actually sad stars are beautiful
this evening
yes do you know who else is beautiful
no who stephen carl stefansson
using the old format with drake in it
using the new improved format with
stephen carl stephenson
i think we should make this the default
there's also a petition
going around i recommend you guys sign
it
for uh to raise a statue of stefan carl
stephenson in his hometown
you can't defeat me i know but they
can't cancer richard uk
americans cancer society if you guys
want to donate as well i'm going to
leave some link in the description
uh i'm going to leave the links in the
description as well and also of course
rest in peace of fun
that's it for me for now meme review
i'll see you guys tomorrow good to be
back
thank you
[Music]